[Music]
Romeo and Juliet are moving to a whole
new garden
all clear not quite perfect but it's
ours think of all the adventures were
gonna have with me
oh man Katie that is just are you done
humans coming poses everyone they were
supposed to live happily ever after but
when their world is in danger Julia
the gnomes broke up there's only one
known to call and Sherlock knows sworn
protector of garden nose you mean except
for the one you literally just broke of
the director of Kung Fu Panda
we can't let anyone hear this but her go
and smashes or or an adventure we have
to get across that River you need a ship
no [ __ ] Sherlock
you've got a great unknown hey our next
clue is in the park directions cricket
just follow the blue line on the ground
until you find the giant red MacAvoy
Emily Blunt - attila chair for mary j
blige having Johnny Depp with original
music by Elton John and Bernie Taupin
they have to go him to cover let's go -
forward hold Oh forgive me I've never
been the back end of a spoiler before
so op no worries that's not how a
squirrel six it's behind mankini can you
demonstrate do you see
yes directing like a rear end
[Music]